et
[Musique]
c'est que nous aurions aimé vous
présenter le spectacle édifiant de
shadocks enfin heureux goûtons les joies
simples d'une terre accueillante et
hospitalière et un repos bien mérité
mais mais la terre autrefois ne
s'appelait pas en réalité la terre non
elle s'appelait la planète jay s
appelait la planète gégène parce qu'elle
appartenait à un certain gène et qui
était un insecte mêmes c'était pas vrai
parce que j'ai gêne en réalité ne
s'appelait pas gégène non plus étant
donné qu'il n'y avait personne pour
l'appeler
comprenez par la suite nous
l'appellerons quand même comme ça pour
plus de simplicité
en ce temps-là il n'arrivait rien de
bien intéressant sur la planète
alors pour passer le temps gêne était
obligé de faire arriver des choses il
s'amusait à faire pleuvoir
[Rires]
il s'amuse est aussi affaire vente
[Musique]
il s'amusait à ferney g avalanche et et
tremblements de terré ou bien ils
bricolaient sa planète
[Musique]
il mangeait une forêt ou deux à son
petit déjeuner et à midi il venait
facilement à bout d'un tas de cailloux
et encore il surveiller son alimentation
ne pas trop si après midi il faisait la
sieste
c'est un après midi comme ça ou gégène
faisait sa sieste que les jib y arriver
puis beaucoup plus tard les shadoks soi
disant pour conquérir la planète
agen mais geiger
allait-il se laisser faire
[Musique]